Ibrahim Racing ya está en Beijing donde
en los próximos tres días se reunirá con
su homólogo o sea sin pin es la primera
visita de Rise a la capital china a la
que ha llegado con seis de sus ministros
y también la primera de un presidente
iraní en 20 años se espera que esta
Cumbre bilateral tenga un gran calado
tanto comercial como geoestratégico ya
que ambas economías son complementarias
y además sufren las sanciones de Estados
Unidos en el caso iraní debido a su
programa nuclear y últimamente por la
venta de drones y otra tecnología
militar a Rusia durante el conflicto con
Ucrania un par de artículos publicados
en las últimas horas en la prensa china
dan la medida de su sintonía el firmado
por raisi en el Diario del pueblo
sostiene que ambos países creen que el
unilateralismo y las medidas violentas
como las sanciones están detrás de las
crisis y la inseguridad que padece el
mundo por su parte el global Times un
medio
ultranacionalista sostiene que las
relaciones bilaterales han podido
fortalecerse a de los sabotajes y las
interferencias de Estados Unidos y que
la salud de esas relaciones
subraya que también fuera del bloque
occidental hay espacio para la
prosperidad de las Naciones china es el
principal socio comercial de Irán Y
aunque se desconocen con exactitud las
cifras un masivo comprador de su
petróleo por su parte china es muy
relevante para Irán por su giro hacia
Oriente que agudizado tras las sanciones
de Estados Unidos